what did you learn in film school that
you didn't already know
i think film school certainly taught me
like a lot of the important basics
of you know cinematography of lighting
of you know
making sure that microphones work in the
best way um but i do think it also
taught me
uh how to be resourceful because i think
for
for me certainly something that happened
was our film school didn't have
you know a giant budget didn't have a
giant production closet with all the
gear we needed and everything like that
um you know a lot of times it would just
be like here's the assignment
uh make sure you find a way to make it
happen and
that's just the way it went and you know
i think a lot of people might see that
as
a drawback but to me like having those
creative restrictions
kind of opened up the freedom a little
bit and it allowed me to
sort of understand the way that i would
later be making a lot of films in the
the quote unquote real world um and i
liked that i didn't ever get
comfortable in the the film school
bubble
because i know a lot of people that get
in the film school bubble and then when
it
pops after graduation they're like what
the real world is crazy you know there's
not people wanting to hold my hand and
you know provide a full lighting kit and
makeup department
you know it it it's it's fine like you
know
that's one way to do it and you know i
truly think there's no
you know right or wrong way but i just
know for me
that seemed to resonate the most with
what i was doing
so you appreciated having to be scrappy
and find things and and resourceful and
and not maybe not things being so easily
provided
yeah yeah absolutely i think for me like
the the scrappiness was almost
the like the fun of it you know it was
almost like
uh solving a puzzle and you know
certainly like there's a lot of headache
that comes with the scrappiness and it's
not glamorous and i mean
you're not gonna sell people on
filmmaking
on the scrappiness alone unless they've
gone through it
um on paper you know if you're just
describing it to someone i think a lot
of times people be like
why would you want to do that you know
why would you put yourself through that
um but i think when you're surrounded
with good people which is uh
majorly majorly majorly important like
making sure the people on your crew the
actors
um they're all in the same headspace
with you if you're in a project with
them
for you know extended periods of time
and you're you know
like staying for late hours and you know
eating
like cheap meals around a campfire in
the woods if you're shooting on location
like
i mean you gotta make sure you like the
people um but yeah i think it's like
when you finally get those circumstances
aligned
uh for me the scrappiness is kind of
like a runner's high like it's like oh
hey we figured it out you know we were
able to do it
despite the you know the setback or the
challenge so
um i always say like be be open to being
scrappy
because i think it's a good skill set
have you always been like that with
other things where you kind of you like
problem solving in some
some capacity like if stuff's too easy
it's almost boring
yeah it's funny like i feel like if
something is too easy you're right it is
a little bit boring and i think like a
lot of times
there's a perception right that things
have to
come easy or things you know if you're
doing it right
if you're successful then you know
you're you're sipping you know drinks at
the beach and you're not thinking about
things and
you know and that's fine for like i
don't know like a week a year
maybe but the rest of the year like i
really do enjoy a challenge like i think
that's why
um i enjoy filmmaking so much is because
you know
trying to to frame you know a tiny
portion of the world in the camera and
this little rectangle
like that's it and that's the challenge
but it's funny like
it sometimes is so all-encompassing like
a lot of times
i will like have to stop myself and be
like wow what i'm doing
is kind of ridiculous like you know
we're all trying to pull this weird shot
off and
you have to be able to almost like laugh
at yourself and be like this is
you know a little silly but at the end
of the day um
it matters and it's you know the the
little tool you take to tell the larger
story
um and i think it's it's like being able
to zoom out
in that fashion that i think uh is
invaluable just to
kind of put you know broader context
into what you're attempting to do as a
storyteller
what did film school not teach you that
maybe there would be no class on it you
just had to find out on your own
yeah there's no curriculum that could
have showed you that yeah
um i think film school you know
it didn't always teach me about
the way the the hardship hits you
when you get out um i knew it would be
difficult
to you know get funding and i knew it
would be difficult
uh you know if i went and did the film
festival circuit because you know
there's certainly a lot of rejection
there's certainly a lot of different
things that happen there
but i think a lot of times they don't
prepare you for the way to deal with it
and that's you know no slide against a
film school that's not really
their thing that almost borders into
like mental health
but i think there is some of that in the
film industry that maybe deserves to be
talked about
um it's that it's okay to get rejected
it's okay
to make a film and have a couple hundred
views on youtube and call it a day
um i think one of the things i've
learned is that you
really can't get caught into your own
work so much as an artist because
uh you know the goal like i mentioned
earlier for me at least is to just
create a body of work
and keep things moving forward at all
times and kind of continuing
a forward momentum and i feel like a lot
of times
if you get too analytical with yourself
you stop moving forward and you stay
really stagnant
um and it's it's challenging because you
know these films a lot of times
they're very personal stories and
they're things that we truly
you know put our all into and so i think
at the end of the day it's certainly
understandable that we care a lot about
them
and we want them to be the best that
they can be um
but you know i think at a certain point
you also
need to know when to walk away like you
know at a certain point you need to say
okay this car i've been driving uh it's
i need to leave it on the side of the
road and get a new car
you know and it's always difficult to do
and i think a lot of times you know it's
going to be a different point for
everyone but
it's finding ways to make sure that you
are always going forward i think that's
uh
one of the biggest challenges in
filmmaking yeah
and i understand you love the office the
tv show the office i do
yeah i love the office um i i love it
because it's so random and i think that
uh
another thing i love about it is it does
a very good job of being funny but also
being very sincere at times too
and i love bait and switch for me every
time i make a movie
i think i bill it a little bit
differently
than people end up maybe taking away
from the final product you know a lot of
times
um people will say oh that looks like a
comedy and they'll walk away and be like
that was a drama wasn't it or vice versa
um
i like to kind of switch things out and
kind of blend the line a little bit
and keep it blurry with genre and i
think yeah the the office
like it does an exceptional job at that
sometimes
so let's say you've written a feature
script and you are going to be
flown to scranton pa to use all of the
cast
as their characters who would you
appoint
as the director oh man um
i actually think stanley would be a
great director stanley from the office
because he's very no-nonsense um
he just wants to get it done and i think
a lot of times
that's undervalued as that kind of
workman
uh like attitude because i think you
would think oh someone's super
charismatic or someone super
artistic maybe better but i think a lot
of times uh
just just realizing that like this is a
thing that needs to get done
a b and c need to be checked off and
then you go home and then you make your
art
um i think sometimes that's undervalued
a lot of times so i think he would be
very good at uh
keeping keeping the train on the track
yeah
and if there was conflict on set as
there sometimes
is what do you think that dynamic what
would happen
if you had all those characters and who
would come in and fix it
who would save the day um ah man you
know i think
pam would be very good at mediating
conflict i think she would be able to
say
okay this is a dumb argument we need to
stop we need to get back on track
um i think like michael and dwight
would probably be the ones stirring the
pot a lot maybe even kevin
inadvertently um but yeah
i now i really want to see a uh office
episode
like as a film set i think that would be
amazing
and and uh one last question then we'll
move on about this so then if there was
a film screening and everybody
got to attend what would the red carpet
be like who was who'd be the one that
would take the most time with all the
answers on the red carpet
oh man um i think creed i think creed
would take a lot of time
and i think creed would take selfies
with every person that asked i think
and he would give them like a different
fact about himself
that you would not know um i i see creed
as being like the
the wild card people person of that crew
you